- THAT GUY TOTALLY RUINED
MY DYNAMITE NAPOLEON IMPRESSION.
[sighs]
NOW WHAT?
I'M WORKING ON SHREK,
BUT...
[imitating Shrek's brogue]
IT'S YEARS AWAY, DONKEY.
- JESUS CHRIST...
YOU OOZE TALENT.
THAT WAS DISGUSTING.
AND I CAN'T EVEN CONCENTRATE
ON THAT
BECAUSE I'M TOO BUSY
HATING THAT DUDE.
- I DON'T BLAME THE GUY,
THOUGH.
HE'S CRANKY 'CAUSE HE HAS TO
WAKE UP SO EARLY
FOR SWIM PRACTICE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
MAYBE WE NEED TO MAKE IT
SO THAT HE NEVER, EVER WAKES UP
FOR SWIM PRACTICE AGAIN.
ONE TIME I WENT SWIMMING
IN, LIKE, THE NEIGHBOR'S POOL
WHEN THEY HAD JUST SHOCKED IT
WITH CHLORINE.
MY SKIN GOT ALL
FIERY RED,
AND MY HAIR STRAIGHTENED OUT
FOR, LIKE, A MONTH.
- WHEN I WAS A TODDLER,
I ACTUALLY FELL
INTO A WASHING MACHINE
FULL OF BLEACH,
AND I DIDN'T GET ITCHY AT ALL.
I DID DIE, THOUGH...
FOR, LIKE, FOUR MINUTES.
THE DOCTORS SAID
THEY COULDN'T BELIEVE
HOW MUCH BRIAN DAMAGE
I DIDN'T GET.
THEY WERE, LIKE,
REALLY IMPRESSED.
THAT WAS FUN. YOU WANNA DO
ANOTHER STORY BATTLE?
I KICKED YOUR ASS.
- NO. I JUST BROUGHT THAT UP
BECAUSE I THOUGHT
WE COULD MAYBE SHOCK
THIS POOL.
- GOOD IDE--
YOU SHOULD HAVE JUST SAID THAT.
- NOW WE'RE TALKING.
ONE OF THESE HAS GOT
TO DO THE TRICK.
- THERE'S, LIKE,
60 MORE BACK THERE, MAN.
- ALL RIGHT.